joe biden you know the most popular
president ever
he got i think a hundred bazillion votes
he's everyone just loves that don't
forget about the opinion polls forget
about the the
dismal approval ratings he's got he's
the most popular guy ever
and there's really great news coming out
of the white house the white house kovid
chief ashish ja
wanted to update us on biden's covet
condition and he told us that joe biden
finished his breakfast like a big big
boy
he slept well last night
uh he ate his breakfast and lunch
i
fully
he actually showed me his plate
didn't ask about the menu but i did see
an empty plate with crumbs and
that's good that's good news that joe
biden's a big big boy and he finished
his breakfast and his lunch and now if
he if he remains a good little boy he
might get some dessert maybe they'll
give joe one of those ice cream cones
that he loves so much hahaha and there's
the press laughing
this kovid chief
is making a joke about how joe biden is
senile that's what the joke is and
that's what the white house is laughing
at
the joke is joe biden is such a
simpleton
in his dotage that he is
he can when he finishes his plate for
breakfast and lunch that's a really big
accomplishment show me show me the clean
plate here you go can i have a lollipop
yes
and then the the
press laughs because everyone knows that
joe biden is seni island it's just
taken as a fact
no wonder the country is falling to pot
so what what is the biden administration
going to do
to turn around the country that is
collapsing in in some part because joe
biden is senile and missing in action
let's just look at the economy the
economy is in shambles it is collapsing
everything is much more expensive than
it was a year ago it's over nine percent
more expensive than it was a year ago
people are having trouble heating their
homes well they don't have to heat them
right now because we have a heat wave
going on but they're having trouble air
conditioning their homes they're having
trouble filling up their gas tanks or
having trouble buying groceries
so what is the white house going to do
about this obvious recession that we're
heading into
well the white house is going to
change the definition of recession
that's what they're going to do this is
what they do you know i hate to say i
told you so i wrote a whole book about
this
now that lives the primary instrument
that they use for changing the political
order is changing all the language
that's why the word marriage matters
they didn't win any debate over what
marriage is they just changed the
definition of marriage that's why the
transgender debate matters they didn't
win any debates over transgenderism they
just changed the definition of man and
the definition of woman now if you
google it the definitions are actually
different because the libs just try to
change reality by
artificially altering the meanings of
the words and now they're doing it with
recession
this from jackie heinrich
bracing for impact
even if thursday's gdp report shows a
second consecutive quarter of negative
growth
you won't hear the biden administration
using the r word here's what here's what
the white house is saying i got it right
off the white house website
well some maintain
what is a recession well some maintain
that two consecutive quarters of falling
real gdp constitutes a recession
that is neither the official definition
nor the way economists evaluate the
state of the business cycle
put a pause there hold on
it's clearly the way
that
some economists uh evaluate the state of
the business cycle
that's clearly i don't know if there is
an official definition but that
definition that they just gave that is
the definition i've heard from my entire
life about what a recession is
two consecutive quarters of falling real
gdp is a recession
but they say no that's not who says who
says
and then the white house concludes it is
unlikely that the decline in gdp in the
first quarter of this year even if
followed by another gdp decline in the
second quarter indicates a recession
but it
it does by definition
that's what a recession is this is this
is exactly the same argument as when
they say just because
a person has two x chromosomes and
breasts and uh womb uh uterus you know
and ovaries that doesn't mean that that
person is a woman
no it does it that's exactly what that
means no but what if it didn't
what if upward down
what if black were white
what if
my aunt had testicles well then she
would be my uncle that's what would
happen they just try to change all of
the words so that is a sign of real
desperation here because they can't do
anything about the economy biden has
tried every trick he's released an
irresponsibly large amount of oil out of
the strategic petroleum reserve to try
to artificially keep gas prices a little
bit lower than their record highs up
until the midterms that strategy ends
just before the midterm so it was just a
political strategy to stop the bleeding
for the democrats he's trying that he's
begging saudi arabia to release more
money he's trying everything that he can
do
other than ramp up american energy which
would irritate his base they're so
desperate
that now the best thing they can do
is just try to change the words
so trying to change the words they're
trying to deny reality they're also now
attempting to jail their political
opponents
steve bannon
the ceo of the trump campaign 2016 a top
advisor to trump in the white house
he was then kind of booted out of the
white house by trump and trump did it in
one of those spectacularly trumpian ways
where he referred to him as sloppy steve
and got into a big fight with him in
public steve bannon though remained
loyal and has remained a trump supporter
steve bannon
may very likely be going to jail now
a dc jury has convicted steve bannon of
two counts of contempt of congress
congress subpoena steve bannon steve
pannin resists and he cites executive
privilege and he cites all sorts of
things and so they prosecute him this is
not often that people will be prosecuted
for this sort of thing and the d.c jury
convicted him which means that bannon
now faces between 30 days to a year in
prison for each of the charges
i want to thank the jury for what the
effort they did the judge particularly
the court administration here everybody
i only have one disappointment and that
is the gutless members of that show
trial committee the j6 committee didn't
have the guts to come down here and
testify in open court thank you very
much
so steve bannon triumphant even as he is
convicted and very possibly going to be
sentenced to jail time
and it it showed one of the real real
miscalculations here from the libs which
is that
this conviction for steve bannon that
they're all gloating over and they're
saying ha ha take that steve c in an
orange jumpsuit this conviction for
steve bannon is the best thing to happen
to him since he was in the white house
maybe steve bannon goes to jail maybe
maybe he goes to jail for 30 days or 60
days
so what
steve bannon has not been this
politically relevant since he was in the
white house
and he left the white house sort of in
disgrace trump was really mean to him on
his way out of the white house and
bannon remained loyal he kept plugging
away
and now he's elevated to this this very
high position
he is going to go down he's going to go
to the trenches he's going to be in the
in jail
for donald trump so i'm not surprised
that steve bannon is gleeful there in
that press conference he's probably
hoping that he gets at least a week or
two in jail
just to build up that credibility and
what does this say for trump trump
should be thrilled about this too
what this says for trump is
trump is is the main threat in the eyes
of democrats
we do
desantis as well i'm not saying desantis
is not a threat i think the democrats
are terrified of him some other
republicans as well they're probably
afraid of they're always attacking ted
cruz i think that is a sign that they do
fear ted cruz to some degree some other
josh hawley a little bit too
but trump is the big one that they're
going after that's why they're trying to
jail his campaign staff
okay that's why they're trying to
take him to court that's why they're
trying to investigate him that's rather
why they're trying to bar him from
running for re-election
if i were trump i would be very happy
with this news because i'd say oh i'm
the number one target okay that means
i'm the one that they fear and trump is
going to sell that message i'm glad you
like that clip
we are so close we are so close to one
million views then i'll get my big gold
play button from youtube then i will put
that outside of my office to boast to mr
ben shapiro and then he will be very
very angry and then probably at that
point youtube will just nuke my whole
channel so it'll be a moot point but
bring me there baby let's do it let's
make it happen we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]